Evet Öncelikle hepiniz hoş geldiniz
Şimdi sizlerle birlikte bu güzel sahnede
bir oyun oynayacağız
Aslında hepinizden gözlerinizi
kapatmanızı istiyorum bir 30 saniye hep
birlikte gözlerimizi kapatalım ve benim
söylediğim şekilde Hayal kurmaya
başlayalım
gözler kapandı mı Evet herkesin gözleri
kapalı dört duvarı çevrili bir duvar
düşünün ve bir odanın
içindesiniz fakat tavan yok Sadece
gökyüzü
var yanınızda bir tane Balyoz Bir de
küçücük lacivert kaplı bir not defteri
var şimdi hayalimizi kurduğumu göre
Sizler de o odanın olduğunuza göre İşte
o odada 18 yaşında var olan karşınızda
gördüğünüz kızı
göreceksiniz o dönem çok zor bir dönemdi
o dönem hayatımın 18 yaşıy dı bugün 42
yaşındayım 18 yaşında büyük hayallerim
vardı ve o hayallerle gözleri açın
lütfen şimdi sırayla gelmek istiyorum
hayatımda en büyük idolüm babamdı babam
18 yaşına kadar çok az onunla
görüşebilirim zaman ayırabilmek
onom Fakat hep idealleri çok yüksek hep
kızının çok iyi yerlerde olmasını
istiyor ve kızına sürekli olarak eğitim
veriyor çocukluğumdan beri eğitim içinde
büyüdüm ve sürekli hedeflerini koy diyor
Ne yaparsan yap oyuncakla bile
oynayacaksan ne oynayacağını önceden
planla diyor çünkü iyi bir Ekonomist iyi
bir iş adamı iyi bir başarıya ulaşmış
biri annem ise birazcık daha kızımdan
yana kızım birazcık daha hayatını kendi
çocukluğunda yaşa istediğin gibi yaşa
ama babanın dediklerini sakın unutma ve
ne olursa olsun ben senin arkandayım
diyen bir anne
var Ve biraz önce o dört duvarı
gördüğünüz O hayal dünyası Aslında benim
odam ve Evet onun bir tavanı var aslında
ama bir de Balyoz koymuştum oraya Çünkü
18 yaşında hayatımın çok az zaman
geçirdiğim o babayı kaybettim trafik
kazasında O günden sonra duygularım
Yalnızlıktan öfkeye dönüştü Çünkü yalnız
kaldığım hissettim Çünkü bana o
hayallerimi vermeye çalışan baba artık
benimle olmayacaktı ve onun la o kadar
az zaman geçirdim ki Ama bundan sonra
tek bir hedefim vardı babamın söylediği
her şeyi uygulamam gerekiyordu şimdi
işte sıra buraya geldi biraz önce
söylediğim o odanın içinde sizlere
lacivert kaplı bir defterden bahsettim o
defterin ilk 6 sayfasını konuşacağım
Bugün sizlerle ve birinci sayfada diyor
ki Pablo Picasso hayal ettiğin her şey
gerçektir der Güzel kızım hayal ine Sıkı
sıkı sarıl Bu benim babamın bana 2000
yılında Ölmeden bir hafta önce hediye
ettiği o lacivert defterin içinin ilk
sayfasıyla Hep boş Yani aslında sen
doldur demek istiyordu fakat ben bunu
daha sonradan anladım ve burada hayal
ettiğin her şey gerçektir dediği an işte
benim O Hayallerim başladı o size
anlattığım balyozu yatak odamda
hayallerimi kurmaya başladım ve dedim ki
ben ne olmak istiyorum ben her şeyden en
önemlisi Turizm mezunuyum ve dedim ki
ben bir restoran Açmalıyım öyle bir
restoran yapmalıyım ki mutfağında Ben
çalışmalıyım misafirlerimi Ben
karşılamalıyım dedim fakat bunu
dediğimde yaşım 18 yaşındaydı ne acı ki
cebimde 5 kuruşta Param yoktu bunlar
Sadece bir hayaldi arkadaşlarıma
anlattığımda 18 yaşında Saçmalama
dediler nasıl yapacaksın param mı var
Hayır yok Peki ne var aileyle bakmakla
yükümlü olduğum bir ailem var ama
Hayallerim hep çok büyük İşte o büyük
hayallerin kızıyım Aslında ben ve derken
o hayali kurmaya başladım İstanbul'da
bir restoran ve dedim ki öyle bir yerde
olmalı ki çok iyi bir semtte olmalı
6 ay sonra rezervasyon için insanlar yer
aramalı diye hayalle yola çıktım ve bir
gün o hayallerle
birlikte İçimdeki sesi dinlemek arkadaki
yazıyı okudunuz zaten İçimdeki ses 5
sene sonra 18 yaşından 5 sene sonra yıl
2005 bir restorana gittim Levent'te iki
katlı bir villa ahşap
2005 yılında Levent Dediğiniz zaman
Bütün herkes orada Türkiye'nin enleri
orada yaşıyor ve Ben Merter'de oturan
bir ailenin kızıyım Belki de yanından
geçemez
diim bir arkadaşımla birlikte restorana
gittik ve içeri girdim içeri girdiğimde
İçimdeki ses Burası senin olacak dedi
İnanır mıydınız Efendim Böyle bir şeye 5
kuruş paranız yokken
Olabilir
mi Olabilir ama değil mi bakalım olmuş
mu yıl 2005 ve içimdeki ses Burası senin
olacak dedi Ve ben o içimdeki sese Hadi
oradan
dedim Çünkü artık Yaşım da ilerlemişti
daha ciddi bakmakla yükümlü olduğum Bir
ailem vardı ve Zordu Ama ben ne
yaptım orada o İçimdeki sesi hiç
bırakmadım y Aki arkadaşıma söylediğimde
o da bana hadi oradan özlem dedi
sonra
hemen babamın söylediği 3 madde Geldi
Karşıma ve dedi ki adını sorduklarında
mutlaka Soyadını da söyle şimdi o
restorand dayız garson geldi masaya
siparişleri aldı yemeği yedik Buranın
sahibi kim diye sordum dediler ki
yukarıda Bey diye biri var buradalar
görüşebilir miyim
dedim 21 yaşını yeni
doldurmuşum cesarete bakın 5 kuruş
paranız yok İçindeki sesi dinleyerek
sahibiyle tanışmak
istedim tanıştım ve tanışırken
babamın şu söylediğini
uyguladım çocukken babam hep söylediği
şey vardı bana adın ne küçük kız senin
dediklerinde Ben Özlem Mekik diye tanıt
kendini
derdi ve o gün ayağa kalktım merhaba
dedim Merhaba dedi beyefendi Ben Özlem
Mekik dedim pardon dedi soyadınızı Bir
daha alabilir miyim dedi işte hayatımın
değiştiği gün ve an Doğan soyadımla
bugünlere geldim Aslında
bakın ve derken o beyefendi tanıştık
dedi ki ben sizin Babanız tanıyorum eğer
doğru kişiyse dedi İstanbul gibi
metropolde Çünkü hayallerimi Artık yavaş
yavaş gerçekleştirmek için çaba
göstermeye başlamıştım artık ve derken
Özlem Mekik deyince babamı tanıdığı için
o restorana 5 kuruş parasız senet
imzalayarak sahibi oldum bir alkış hak
etmiş
miyim
ve 4 sayfa babamın yazdığı Rotası
olmayan gemiye hiçbir Rüzgar Yardım
edemez dedi babam ve bana hep rotanı
belirle dedi artık bir restoranım var
bütün Türkiye tanıyor bütün magazin
programları Ziyade Fasıl diye bir ismi
biliyor ve Türkiye'de olmayanı yaptım
bir fasıl müziğini ilk modern müziği
koydum ve ederken mutfağında çalışmaya
başladım misafirlerimi ben karşıladım ve
O hayal ettiğim 6 ay önceden
rezervasyonlar dolacak dediğim o
Restoran bir sene sonraya rezervasyon
almaya başladı çünkü kişiye özel hizmet
etmeye başladım Çünkü kendimi anlatmak
istedim Çünkü hissettiğimi vermeye
başladım ve rotamı Oradan sonra
belirledim dedim ki ben bu kadar iyiysem
mutfakta da bu kadar başarılıysa
ekranlardan yemek programları teklifleri
gelm başladı ve artık 2010 yılı
itibariyle ekranlarla tanışmaya başladım
Çünkü Türkiye'nin enlerini artık kendi
restoranım ağırlıyordu ve
ağırladığımız teklifleri almaya başladım
yatırım teklifleri almaya başladım
bambaşka bir özlem me kek oluşmaya
başladı artık ve derken en önemlisi
de çok yoğun çalışma hayatım olmaya
başladı televizyonlarda her gün yemek
programı
yapıyorum artık ismim duyuldu
gazetelerde yazıyorum Türkiye'nin en
büyük gazetelerinde yemek yazıları yemek
eleştirmenliği
yapıyorum Ve bu arada eğitim almaya
devam ediyorum 95 tane eğitim aldım
yaptığım işle ilgili Çünkü babamın
söylediği şey şi hep tekrar ettim
derken yıl
2017 Bu kadar çalışma hayatı bu kadar
her şeyi belirledik ve o 2017
yılında artık UNESCO var
önümüzde dedim ki Çanakkale Vali ile
birlikte ve Opet petrolcülük
önderliğinde hep birlikte Troya yılı
kapsamında biz UNESCO'ya gittik
UNESCO'da ilk insanoğlunun yediği
tatlıyı 800 kişilik dünya liderlerine
sundum ve anlattım bundan daha kuvvetli
bir şey olabilir
mi ve o da
bitmedi kör Tadım yapmak Hayatımın en
önemli noktasındayım 2019 yılında
Brüksel'de Merkezi bulunan
dünyada kör Tadım yapan o yıl 148
masterchef'ten
Türkiye'den sadece tek kadın olarak ve
dünyadan 3 kadın olarak kör Tadım uzmanı
oldum Tabii bunları yaparken hep çok
büyük emeklerle yaptım UNESCO'ya gitmek
için o Reçeteyi bulmak için 7 sene
çalıştım sanat tarihçilerle çalıştım
yılmadım Halbuki işim gücüm yerindeydi
Bu saatten sonra hiçbir şeye ihtiyacım
yoktu maddi olarak ama bir şeye
ihtiyacım vardı hedeflerime ulaşmak
Çünkü hedeflerim çok
büyüktü Fakat bu işte Ne yazık ki son
madde bir gün kalkacaksın ve
hayallerinin tümünü gerçekleştirmek için
artık çok geç
olabilir yıl 2017'de
hala telefonum çaldı Doktorum aradı dedi
ki gelmen lazım Anladım O bir şey
olduğunu dedim ki bir şey var Bir hafta
geçmişti Çünkü
tahlillerim ve yanına çağırdığında
ne yazık ki dedi
kansersin İşte o an hayatımın yıkılma
anıydı o an babamın bu madde benim
hayatımda dedim ki evet bu kadar koştun
bu kadar çabaladın bu kadar başarı için
her şeyi yapt başardın Evet uluslararası
platformlarda Artık adın geçiyor
Türkiye'den daha çok dünya tanıyor beni
ama kendini
atladın ne yazık ki bunu yaparken
kendine gereken zamanı ayırmadın ve o
çok sevdiğim saçlarım ekranlarda olduğum
o günlerde saçlarım dökülmeye başladı Şu
anda da olduğu gibi kısacık saçlarla
dolaşmaya başladım ama bir yaptığım bir
şey vardı hayatta Onlar için çaba
gösterdiğim ailemden bunu saklamak
istedim 4 sene sakladım 4 sene hiç
kimsenin ne ekranda ne Bulunduğum yerde
haberi olmadı operasyona girdim tek
başıma girdim imkansız bir şey başardım
Çünkü imkansız ve 4 sene ben kanser
değilmişim gibi yaşadım evet daha çok
çalıştım çünkü kendimi işime verdim daha
çok zaman geçirdim ve bir damla
gözyaşlarına kıyamayacağınız
son sayfası babamın artık sizlere
anlatmak istediğim bana dedi ki ne
yaparsan yap Hep not al Ben küçücük
defterlere hala çok notlar alırım ve
kendime O günden sonra not almaya
başladım ve o
notlarım her gün Kendime soruyorum
Nasılsın uyandığımda ilk yaptığım şey
nasıl olduğumu sormak oluyor Kendime ve
ikincisi
nasıl hissediyorsun ve bunları
cevaplandırıyor üncüsü sağlıklı mısın
Evet başarı çok kıymetli ama başarmanın
yanında en kıymetli şey aslında sağlık
olduğunu anladım peki huzurlu musun
yastığa başını koyduğunda gerçekten
istediğin noktada mısın kendini mutlu
huzurlu hissediyor musun diye soruyorum
Vicdanın rahat mı bugün atladığın
çevrende gülümsemediğin onları üzdüğün
kimse oldu mu ekip arkadaşların
elemanların kimse var mı ya da dostların
diye hep soruyorum ve en önemlisi 42
yaşındayım sevdiğinde seni seviyorum
diyebiliyor musun aşık olduğunda
diyebiliyor musun Biliyor
musunuz kanseri geçirdiğim 5
yılındayız Raporu aldım
ve en kuvvetli başardığım şey şu an çok
güzel sen seviyorum diyorum Aşık
olduğumda aşık oldum diyebiliyorum keşke
bunu yaşamadan önce demeyi becersin ve
deseydim gerçekten çok daha kıymetli
olurdu ama ne yazık ki diyemedim Keşke
deseydim hayatta her şeyi kabul ettim
kabullenişi Kabul ettim ve Hayatta en
sevdiğim kelime hep Eyvallah oldu
bugünden sonra ne yaşarsam yaşayayım hep
Eyvallah demeyi bildim teşekkür etmeyi
bildim saygı duymayı bildim ve hayal
kurmayı
öğrendim 18 yaşımda girdiğim bu yolda
hayalini kurduğum bir yolun aslına
bakarsanız hayallerin ne kadar özgür
olduğunu
öğrendim Biraz önce sizi götürdüğüm o
duvarlar var ya hepsini yıktın dediler
ki gece hayatımın olmaz ama oldu
böyle bir iş yapamazsın dediler
yaptım dünyaya açılamaz sın Türkiye'de
Master şf yok dediler
gittim Hayal kurduğunuz her şey çok
özgür ve Hayal kurmak bedava bunun bir
veresiyesi yok alacağı yok vereceği yok
ne yaparsanız yapın önce hayal kurmayı
öğrenin Aşık olacağınız insanı dahi
hayal edin çünkü ha Ettiğiniz her şey
sizin karşınıza mutlaka Bilgin çıkıyor
Ve o yüzden de hayallerinizi Özgür
bırakmayı öğrenin Biraz önce bir şeyden
bahsettim dedim ki Eyvallah demeyi çok
seviyorum benim için hayattaki Çünkü
Eyvallah bir kabulleniş oldu kansere de
eyvallah dedim battık lım da da eyvallah
dedim Bu arada Tabii bu başarıyı
anlattım başarısızlıklarım var yanında
böyle kapattığım ü restoran var hani
demiyorum ki ben süperi başardım bunu da
başarmadan zamanlar oldu ama hep
güzelini hayal ettim hep iyisini hayal
ettim üstüne üstüne üstüne koyarak
Yaşamaya çalıştım ve o eyvallahı da hep
onlar için kullandım benim hayatımda bu
saatten sonra olan her şeye Eyvallah
diyorum ben ve şimdi Sizler de o
hayalini kurdunuz şöyle bir 50 saniye
sizleri tekrar gözlerinizi kapatmaya
davet ediyorum lütfen 18 yaşındaki Özlem
gibi gözlerinizi kapatın dört duvarlı
olan o od Dayın içindeki balyozu alın ve
yıkın o duvarları hayallerinizi kurmaya
başlayın 50 saniye o gözlerinizi
kapatın Kimi görmek istiyorsanız kiminle
birlikte orada olmak istiyorsanız o
odada ne yapmak istiyorsanız o duvarları
yıkın Çünkü hayatınızdaki duvarları
yıkarsanız başarıya ulaşabilirsiniz
ancak Kimin ne dediğinin hiçbir önemi
yok ki sizin inizin çok önemi var çünkü
unutmayın Bizler ailelerimizin getirdiği
insanlarız ve kimi zaman enkazda
olabiliyoruz O yüzden bu tamamen benim
hayatımda Kurduğum en kıymetli şey
aslında başaramazsın kimseye demeyin Kim
Ne Derse Desin kırın o duvarları
balyozlar göreceksiniz hayatınız
bambaşka bir noktaya gelmiş olacak ve
bundan sonraki Hayallerim ne benim
Biliyor musunuz evlenmek artık çocuk
sahibi olmak istiyorum Bence hayattaki
en güzel şeylerden biri de aslına
bakarsanız bu O yüzden Sizler de
hayallerinizi belirleyin bazı şeyler
için çok geç olabilir geç olduktan sonra
da zaten hiçbir anlamı yok ve benim hep
söylediğim bir şey var Kendinizi sevin
ve bir röportajım da söylemiştim ve en
çok da TT olan şeylerden biri Çünkü
kendinizi sevmezseniz Bir gün olmayan
saçını sevmek zorunda kalırsınız
Hayattaki en zor şey ne biliyor musunuz
gördüklerinizi bir daha görmemek hepiniz
yaşamışsınız Bunu o yüzden de ama her
şeye Eyvallah diyerek bakın Çünkü
hayattaki en güzel şey kabul etmektir
kabul ettiğiniz her şeyi de yaşarsınız
bu hayatta ve son
olarak
İzninizle bana o lacivert kaplı defteri
hediye eden elleriyle yazan çok az
tanıdığım idolüm olan babama Eyvallah
saygıyla demek istiyorum ve çok kıymetli
anneme
ve Bugün sizlerle bir araya getiren
tedex ekibine tedex denizliye sonsuz
teşekkür ediyorum saygıyla
eyvallah